FOR THURSDAY MARCH TWELFTH IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE
REVISE AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS DEBATE AS ALL
TELEVISED MAN SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM. YEAH FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER HERE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA. FROM HERE
RIVAS YEAH WITH THIS. OKAY WE
HAVE A C<c.cyan> AND- WE HAVE A</c>
PROPOSED CONSENT AGENDA BEFORE
US TODAY. SURE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO REMOVE A REFERRAL OF
YOU SEE EIGHTY FIVE CENTS BASED
ON ITS CONTENT WHICH IS SIMILAR
TO S. C. EIGHTY FIVE FROM
TWENTY THIRTEEN THEY SHOULD BE
REFERRED TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ASKED THAT
WE SEPARATELY. HELLO IT WILL
HAVE SEVEN VOTE ON THAT MATTER
IS A MOST REMAINDER THAT CAN
AGENDA SOME OF MOVE BY MR
MATHIS SECONDED BY HIS QUIRK
SILVA OF MATTER CENTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE- CONSENT
AGENDA. COOLEY HI. ALL RIGHT
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER
I MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK
SILVA AYE RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS
RIVAS I WORK. OF WICKS CONSENT.
RIGHT TIME THAT MOTION. OKAY IS
THERE A MOTION REFERRAL ACA.
FIVE TO PC IN ARKHAM. WHO ON
WITH HER SECOND WE SECOND HOMES
RAMOS TO HAVE A QUESTION INDEED
IF I A MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY
JUST BECAUSE THAT THIS IS THE-
VOTE AND NOT AN ACTUAL BOOK THE
CA CORRECT ALL THEY'RE ALL THE-
MOTIONS TO SENATE BILLS TO
COMMITTEE IS JUST A PROCESS
BOTH. TECHNICAL THING AND PUT
SOME FOR THE POLICY WE WENT
POLICY ISSUES THANK. IN
ADDRESSED. ALSO HAVE A MOTION
SIR MANAGE PIECE CALL THE ROLL.
CALLING COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CAREER. CARILLO AYE FLORA SO
FLORA GRAY HI GRAYSON AYE CAN'T.
GOOD KAMLAGER I. MATHIS MATHIS
NO SILVA NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA
NOT VOTING. PROMESAS RAMOS I
RIVAS. RIVAS I WORK SITE WHICH-
CSUS IS THE MOST PASSED OF I
WILL. MAY HERE FROM ISRAELI AND
A GREAT WERE SENT FROM THE ALSO
THE HIGHER AND. THAT STORY
BEING AFFECTS. OF THE. AT THE.
MEDIA THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THURSDAY MARCH TWELFTH IS
HEREBY INJURE THANK YOU FOR.